la indignación internacional las
ejecuciones a cuatro activistas
prodemocracia que anunció la junta
gobernante de mianmar este lunes trajo
un rápido rechazo de organizaciones
internacionales de derechos humanos
periodistas y de naciones unidas- los
condenados a muerte tras varios juicios
a puerta cerrada fueron acusados a
ayudar a insurgentes a luchar contra el
ejército que tomó el poder en febrero de
2021 en intentos fallidos la comunidad
internacional ha hecho varios llamados
para que la junta militar ponga fin a
los procesos contra activistas y se teme
que más opositores estén en la lista de
espera para ser ejecutados calculamos
que puede haber al menos 140 personas
que están en el corredor de la muerte
los militares tienen planeado seguir
llevando a cabo de ejecuciones mientras
siguen bombardeando pueblos y deteniendo
a personas inocentes en todo el país
las autoridades militares a través de
esta especie de tribunales inventados en
donde han acortado los procedimientos
que no tienen prácticamente ningún
derecho de apelación ningún derecho de
clemencia
hemos visto que esencialmente el uso de
la pena de muerte se ha convertido en
una parte integral de la retención del
poder
reprimiendo la oposición
el gobierno japonés ha condenado a las
ejecuciones las primeras en tres décadas
y la vecina china aunque ha puesto por
delante del principio de no injerencia
ha dicho que el país debe resolver sus
diferencias y conflictos rápidamente
pero los birmanos piden menos diplomacia
en más acciones concretas la respuesta
de la comunidad internacional sólo son
palabras ya sabes cómo vamos a hacer
esto nos preocupamos hicimos aquello
blah blah blah ya sabes no hay nada en
acción si hubiera algo en acción este
tipo de ejecuciones no ocurriría ni al
mar está sumido en un caos desde el
golpe de estado del año pasado en donde
se calcula que más de dos mil
manifestantes murieron luego de que las
fuerzas de seguridad utilizaron munición
real en contra de los civiles